partirò dalla esplorazione dei segni
dell'espressione è una Mission
multiforme e multitasking molte forme
perché le lingue storiche naturali sono
davvero tante sei settemila almeno
censite
multitasking perché le lingue sono
sistemi complessi e lo sono anche i
testi
versatili possono essere sganciati da
noi locutori attraversare tempi e spazi
straordinari ma nello stesso tempo
accompagnare il nostro presente e
orientare il nostro futuro
cercherò in breve di ricostruire un po'
una storia che mi vede coinvolta
dall'anno della maturità era giugno e fu
invitata a un ritiro di un giorno tenuto
da un
gesuita da un padre gesuita che non
conoscevo di cui non conoscevo
l'esistenza era Roberto Busa aveva una
sessantina d'anni eravamo ospitati in
questo magnifico posto
costruito fra il 500 e L'Ottocento e lui
non parlò assolutamente di ciò che lo
occupava ferialmente ma scoprì poi che
era già noto internazionale come un
pioniere della linguistica
computazionale
lo cercai L'anno dopo quando da
matricola di filosofia Volevo inserire
nel mio piano di studi filosofia del
linguaggio che in università Cattolica
Allora non c'era e mi suggeria Allora di
studiare linguistica generale cosa che
feci e che non mi sarei mai aspettata
avrebbe fatto sì che diventassi poi
fatta madrina diciamo così
dell'innesto di linguistica
computazionale in università Cattolica
proprio perché
il tempo passa fu poi padre Busa a
chiedere consiglio a me quando lui ormai
novantenne stava cercando di disporre la
sua passaggio di consegne e quindi ormai
il tempo dei pionieri possiamo dire si
era concluso era il tempo del team
building era il tempo della
istituzionalizzazione accademica dei
altri progetti di ricerca in questo
senso e dunque partì un progetto che dal
2004 adesso al 2023 ha visto registrare
dei passi non proprio di piccola
dimensione ma cerchiamo di entrare in
medias e dunque vi dirò perché mi
interessava il linguaggio e ritenessi
che fosse così meritevole di
esplorazione
lo ritenevo e lo ritengo manifestativo
del pensiero come abbiamo più volte
sentito oggi e anche capace di far
maturare in noi pensieri e affetti che
da soli non sapremmo estrarre da noi
stessi e dunque L'idea era di
apprezzare quanto di pensiero e di
cultura potesse attraversare il
linguaggio e passare attraverso di esso
ma anche l'attaccamento alla realtà
delle lingue storiche naturali e vi farò
un esempio pensiamo a un'immagine
semplice come quella di una piega in
latino Clicca e pensiamo a quanti
concetti e realtà si
servano di questa raffigurazione così
semplice per dire di concetti alti di
ruoli sociali diffusi e rilevanti
pensiamo quindi
esplicito esplicito implicato così
diversi tra la logica della
conversazione e la logica del calcolo
logico ma anche agli impiegati alle
spiegazioni e anche a quel modo di dire
che ci parla di imperturbabilità
dell'animo quando appunto diciamo non
facciamo una piega
Allora veniamo a Busa abusa che si era
dottorato nell'immediato secondo
dopoguerra e aveva scritto una tesi
sulla in filosofia sul linguaggio
domestico dell'interiorità
il sottotitolo diceva a note di metodo
sulla metafisica della presenza
senz'altro a questo livello i metodi e
lepistemologia sono molto importanti
in queste note di metodo si racchiudeva
un po' quello che a distanza di qualche
anno nel 51 avrebbe scritto la chiusura
dell'introduzione di un suo piccolo
volume scriveva così ho dato così un
saggio che ritengo invitante delle
grandi e piccole comodità in realtà sono
laboriose assai con cui le macchine per
contabilità e statistica possono amrire
allo studioso il materiale degli indici
infatti indexstomistico come indice
altre Si possono escogitare e Chi vorrà
segnalarci quanto ancora ci appaia di
difettoso da togliere o di desiderabile
da aggiungere oltre che aver dato a noi
un ambito riconoscimento dell'utilità
del nostro sforzo avrà anche contribuito
ad un più proficuo lavoro di tanti e io
me lo immagino sorridente mentre
scriveva queste cose all'inizio degli
anni 50 sapendo quanta diffidenza quanto
sconcerto avrebbe potuto generare nei
suoi poco più che 25 lettori
in realtà in nel testo che appunto era
la pubblicazione stampa della sua tesi
di laurea di due anni prima del 49 aveva
raccontato proprio come era cambiato il
focus rispetto a un'indagine che non era
come quella tradizionale di studio dei
manuali Diciamo ad mentendome Ma che
voleva dire rapporto diretto democrazia
soprattutto carotaggio e trattamento
indicizzazione concordanza dei testi
come potete leggere l'indagine da me
compiuta su San Tommaso dei cui
risultati si compone questo mio libro e
varie sondaggi praticati a ricercare in
Aristotele Plotino Sant'Agostino
Alessandro Di al Sant'Alberto Magno San
Bonaventura Non tanto gli enunciati
teoretici propri a ciascuno quanto
direttamente l'impiego dei mezzi
espressivi scelti a significarla
porteranno a concludere perché le
conclusioni teoriche poi c'erano che
l'interiorità per la scolastica e per
San Tommaso Spazia in tre piani
dell'essere del pensiero dell'anima il
dispiegamento di nuovo la plica e la
piega dei segni verbali che regge la
complessità di questa triplice trama
risulterà veramente imponente e la cosa
più forse carina davvero affascinante è
che non tanto l'occorrenza di un termine
astratto come inte realtà quanto le sedi
in cui compariva la preposizione in e
naturalmente ciò che La seguiva potevano
svelare In che cosa consiste consistesse
questa triplice interiorità questo
quindi era un progetto dell'inizio degli
anni 50 e qua vedete l'imponente
realizzazione dell'Opera che fu
pubblicata tra il 1976 e il 1980
lindesdomisticos appunto che aveva
attraversato prima di arrivare a questa
forma cartacea che non è nemmeno
l'ultima tutta una serie di passaggi
tecnologici che
attestavano di quanto l'umanista si
apprezzasse in collaborazione con gli
esperti di tecnologia per dare forma a
questa documentazione che quale è pregio
aveva e quale sfida cercava di
raccogliere il superamento della
potremmo dire saggistica Artigian perché
assolutamente individuale delle Scienze
Umane Nel nostro caso in filosofia che
invece si traduceva in qualcosa di
accessibile a tutti di controllabile di
ripercorribile e di suscettibile di
essere sottoposto a prova Vediamo
l'edizione a stampa di un volume
dell'edilizio Leonina almeno non si
partiva dai manoscritti Ma questo Nulla
toglie al merito dei filologi e poi si
passava
allenticizzazione attraverso le schede
perforate poi attraverso i nastri
magnetici
poi attraverso il cd rom nel 1989 e nel
2006 alla accessibilità in rete ormai è
nel web da una buona
quindicina e più danni
Naturalmente tutto questo fu possibile
grazie alla Persuasione della IBM e di
mecenati che resero possibile
soprattutto in ambito Lombardo nel
Gallaratese la trascrizione su schede
perforate di questo lavoro
minuziosissimo di indicizzazione e che
quindi rese possibile l'attuazione e la
circolazione dei risultati di questo
lavoro
cerchiamo adesso di recuperare la il
filo conduttore che ci aggancia ai tempi
a noi più vicini Appunto nel 2004
capì che padre usa cercava L'approdo
dentro il sistema accademico di questo
progetto che aveva condotto veramente da
pioniere e andando oltreoceano a New
York per avviarlo e nel 2006 fu
reclutato come assegnista di ricerca il
professor Marco Passarotti Eccolo lì che
adesso dirige il Circe cioè il centro
interdisciplinare per la ricerca per la
sulla computerizzazione dei segni
dell'espressione che era un classicista
molto
prontamente precocemente entrato nella
dimestichezza del trattamento automatico
del linguaggio e nello stesso tempo era
un ricercatore di scienze del linguaggio
molto sul pezzo qua Vedete un passaggio
di consegna abbastanza storico padre bu
sempre più anziano e sempre più
compiaciuto di avere trovato questo modo
di traghettare al centro la figura di
Luca Nicola Scusate ciniero che era la d
di BM Italia e noi stavamo per
l'Università Cattolica che ha recepito
il fondo la biblioteca e mentre i volumi
dell'index erano già in sala
consultazione da gran tempo bene
nel 2018
l'Unione Europea attraverso lo European
Research Council her see fondato nel
2007 finanzia con una selezione
durissima questo progetto con l'acronimo
Lila link inglesi il cui obiettivo
quinquennale quindi scade fra un mese il
cui obiettivo qua potete leggere il to
Connect an Ultimate le exploit The Walls
of linguistico
descriptions
Questa è una assolutamente più che
veloce idea di come la nostra stringa di
linearizzazione di una frase
assolutamente Latina in questo caso ha
bisogno di una serie di relazioni per
comporre dei sintagmi e qua vedete
secondo la grammatica dipendenza e
l'estrazione del predicato eventualmente
di un ausiliare predicativo come potest
e poi tutta la ramificazione che è
tipica della costruzione di ogni nostra
frase Questo è lo sviluppo morfologico e
l'ammirazione admiro Ramiro c'è la forma
attiva ci sono poi le varie coniugazioni
gli aspetti di aggettivazione eccetera
cioè quella fioritura che ogni lingua
storico naturale ha come ci raccontavamo
prima con piega bene Questo è solo un
flash per ritornare al punto quale è
diciamo stata la linea di sviluppo si
sono soprattutto curate le relazioni
sintattiche Questo risponde a una
maturazione della teoria linguistica più
che quelle lessicali e soprattutto si è
ci si è occupati del latino lungo un
arco di 1.300 anni da Virgilio appunto a
Tommaso D'Aquino e si potrebbe andare
avanti perché non solo la filosofia ma
anche la scienza scrive in latino fino
quasi tutto il Settecento alterna lingue
moderne al latino Ma questo è vero
ancora per
[Musica]
Kant è vero ancora per Galileo è vero
per leibniz eccetera Dunque L'idea è di
mettere a disposizione di una comunità
gli studiosi le cosiddette linguistiche
sono composition of linguistic Material
Used in the Construction improvement and
o evaluation of language processions
Applications di nuovo le pieghe e
language and language mi dieted studys
and Applications Appunto allora questa
disponibilità di risorse
raccolte
digitalizzate
annotate naturalmente si offre anche a
una prospettiva
molteplice di lavori che non riguardano
soltanto certamente non solo la
filosofia o la letteratura ma anche la
storia in questa raccolta di testi sul
1300 anni di storia ci sono anche
testi legislativi atti notarili ci sono
scritti EPI 12 quindi una testimonianza
culturale veramente la calcioreral
Heritage riportata in un formato
accessibile e distribuibile Ma c'è anche
tutta una dimensione di attenzione al
fatto che come oggi abbiamo tante volte
potuto sentire apprezzare c'è una
diciamo mediazione linguistica in
tantissimi ambiti quindi la
pianificazione di contenuti per il Web
la customer interaction molte dimensioni
applicative mi è piaciuto molto la
parola chiave di questo Ted e quindi
l'idea che è forte in filosofia del
linguaggio è sì throwars ma in towards e
mi sembra importante capire che tutto
questo merita tanta scienza ma anche
tanta Sapienza Quindi c'è un metodo
rigoroso senza il quale le macchine non
collaborano ma al tempo stesso nulla si
toglie all'empatia che ci è necessaria
per leggere per ascoltare e per entrare
in relazione con gli autori o i contesti
che si avvalgono di parole per
relazionarsi a noi un ultimo cenno che
vuole essere una nota per certi aspetti
un po' laconica ma anche una qualche
provocazione abbiamo visto passare sotto
gli occhi rapidamente una settantina
d'anni dagli approdi newyorkesi di Busa
alla situazione di Lila e alla dozzina
di giovani che Cercatori che ci stanno
lavorando
c'è un Gap abbiamo letto anche in una
definizione precedente che c'era un
briging the gap ed è quello che a mio
avviso in buona misura ancora paralizza
un po' gli scambi tra scienze umane e
queste risorse tecnologiche quindi il
mio desiderio sarebbe proprio che non
succeda che avete visto quel bel palazzo
antico
accada come che ci siano nella scuderia
delle macchine potenti
biologiche capaci di farci fare davvero
delle esplorazioni che a occhio nudo non
possiamo fare anche se siamo esperti di
un autore di un testo e che rimangano lì
perché sia un po' timore che prendano la
mano oppure si pensa che non siano
abbastanza eleganti abbastanza fini per
quella specificità per quella
particolarità che è proprio il
contrassegno di ciò di cui le scienze
umane si occupano quindi
vedremo
diciamo i posteri poi ci aiuteranno a
capire se questa sfida verrà raccolta Io
intanto ringrazio molto voi e ciascuno
di coloro che sentendosi
interpellato da questa avventura possa
dire come capitò a me tanti tanti anni
fa quando vedevo difficilissimo il
traghettare questa impresa solitaria nel
sistema accademico e anche nel sistema
della ricerca internazionale
che se sono cose e fioriranno Grazie
[Applauso]